Hey everyone tickets are now on sale for marvel
studios black widow we have to
go back to where it all started
grab your tickets today or else
or else what where else you know
david what no we're not doing that
what you know it's a gesture for
or else you won't have tickets no david yeah
that's no that's what that gesture means no but
where are we trying to get
motorbike east side of the building
three two run action
black widow is something that the marvel universe
has never experienced before the action in this
film is real you these huge armored vehicles
going through these iconic streets in budapest
budapest itself is so important to whom natasha
really is and what drives her and she finds this
family from her past there so we're gonna
talk like grown-ups is that what we are
within like two days of knowing scarlet
i was just ramming her into a door frame
all the fighting in this film is so emotional
and about not knowing how to say what you feel
it's good to see you too sis there's some
of the most intense fights that we've had
in the mcu there's this big fight scene
in this enormous prison there were 400
this doesn't extras like a movie it feels real
i wanted to create something really visceral and
fun but to talk about natasha as a human being
to let audiences see a sign of her
that they had never seen before
i've spent a decade of time with this character
and she's finally able to write her own
story i'm done running for my past
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
black widow trailer video there's obviously a ton
of new footage marvel was not joking when i was
talking about them releasing the entire movie in
little short two-minute clips but we only have
a couple weeks to go we're doing a giveaway for
disney plus memberships and i'll do a giveaway
for movie tickets too if you wind up winning
you can pick either one that you want all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your theories about what happens with the
new version of black widow after the black widow
movie so the big thing with this new footage
is that there's a whole bunch of stuff going
on here a bunch of really cool fight scenes just
showing you how crazy things get but there are a
couple specific scenes in here that reveal who
taskmaster is that you probably spotted and we
basically have what amounts to the opening scene
of the movie with black widow going to budapest
but i'll start with the taskmaster stuff first
just because there's still so many crazy theories
about what's going on with taskmaster but i do
feel like this footage and some of these scenes in
here completely answer this so in the new footage
there's a much better example of who taskmaster is
when he's in the middle of this big fight with
red guardian in this facility wherever they're
experimenting on the black widows is the same
place where you see taskmaster watching back
all the avengers footage copying their moves
he starts brawling with red guardian shows
off his avengers moves like we've seen the black
panther moves with the vibranium claws he pulls
a spider-man back flip kick a captain america
shield stomp then in the new footage he shows
he's got a retractable blade in his gauntlet
that's not meant to be a wolverine move or
anything like that we don't have wolverine in the
mcu at least yet and none of the classic avengers
characters use wrist blades that are that big so
you can pick your reference as to which avenger
you think he copied that move from but when he's
about ready to spear red guardian with the blade
molina vostakov rachel weiss's character blocks
him and does her own version of that signature
black widow spinning leg takedown move it's the
same move that black widow used on winter soldier
it's one of her go-to classics and since molina
was kind of a mother too natasha black widow when
she was growing up i think they're trying
to imply that she learned some of her moves
from molina as a child but as you probably guess
where i'm going with this the obvious thing here
is that molina is literally fighting taskmaster
a completely separate character in this scene so
hopefully that'll take everybody off the rachel
vice taskmaster theories but for example here
when they're getting ready to brawl red guardian
and taskmaster the person in the costume is about
as tall as david harper and look how tall david
harbor is compared to scarlett johansson i mean
she's already tiny in real life so it looks like
an even bigger difference but think about which
other characters standing here on stage next to
david harbor at comic con are about as tall as he
is so i just think it's more evidence confirming
that it's really the mason character played by ot
fagbenle and he's playing dual roles in the movie
we already know that for some of the movie he's
playing a character called mason the character the
black widow gets all of her gear her weapons from
anything that she needs when she goes on missions
it's implied that they have some sort of sexual
relationship in the past or in the present and i
think the idea with the big taskmaster twist as
i've said before is that it's going to be this
big betrayal when it's revealed who's inside
the mask like oh the person you trusted this
whole time you were in this relationship with
was secretly pulling the strings behind the black
widow program this whole time the very thing that
you've been trying to take down the whole thing
with rachel vice's character though because her
name is molina vostakov and she is the iron maiden
character in the comics a black widow villain a
lot of people were still kind of expecting her to
be connected to taskmaster somehow in the red room
when she did her big interview about the movie
she said that since natasha had defected to the
united states started working for nick fury been
part of the avengers all these years she'd been
living on this farm raising pigs experimenting
on them so early theory some of the research
that she's been doing as a scientist has been
actually helping taskmaster and drakov brainwash
the other black widows so maybe unwittingly
she's been helping the new black widow program
and for instance here too when they're in this
giant big action scene you see some other armored
people that look similar to taskmaster's armor but
this isn't taskmaster this is just another person
with armor that's like taskmaster so it sounds
like they're trying to create more task masters
so to speak like create more characters that
can do what he does and replicate his abilities
this sort of goes hand in hand with the idea of
the super soldier program everybody wants their
super soldiers in these different countries i also
love the footage in here of david harper's red
guardian character going full hulk in that giant
prison yard fight in siberia you get a much better
sense of his super soldier powers so if you're
not familiar with a red guardian character in
the comics he's basically the russian version of
captain america developed by the soviet government
separate from hydra's winter soldier program
they're like a whole separate group doing things
in siberia on their own they're not connected
to the russian government although they do have
members infiltrating the russian government
they kind of addressed this during falcon and
winter soldier when nagel is talking about his
history developing his new version of the super
soldier serum in the weapons plus program how
he kind of bounced around to different places
different people hired him like hydra hired him
for a little while in the comics at least the
black widows when they graduate from the red room
in addition to sterilizing them so they're not
capable of getting pregnant they would also give
the new black widows a form of the super soldier
serum now it was a diluted form so it wasn't like
the full dose that captain america got but that's
why in the comics black widow this tiny little
person is able to run around with the other a-list
avengers with legit super powers and hold her own
they never really addressed the idea that maybe
natasha got a form of the super soldier serum
when she went through the program but because
this is the black widow movie this would be the
place to explain that whether she did or she did
not the way they've been playing the character
for the last 10 years or so since iron man 2
seems like she does not have the super soldier's
serum it just feels like all of her attacks would
land way harder if she had super soldier serum
in her body but then they have that big opening
scene where the new squad of black widows and
taskmaster come to get natasha and yelena belova.
Yelena apparently has set a bunch of booby traps
around her apartment in budapest what happens in
budapest stays in budapest i am sure there will be
plenty of budapest jokes it just seems like she's
rigged the circuit from all the light switches
to blow when she turns it on that's also probably
her just taking advantage of really shoddy super
old wiring like no joke a long time ago i lived
in this really crappy new york city apartment
that was the size of a broom closet and it was
a miracle that i didn't get electrocuted every day
just turning the light switches on and apparently
in this scene one of the black widows would
rather kill natasha than apparently be saved by
her like she tries to save her and the other one
just eats out 40 or 50 feet below to the ground
they just want to show you how hardcore the new
black widow program has become in the extreme
tactics that the new widows use to take out their
targets like completely ignoring their own lives
in pursuit of a target yelena belova has that
narration in the other trailers where she explains
that taskmaster and drakov are essentially
brainwashing the new recruits even more than
what was done to natasha and her when they came
up through the red room but this will overlap
with the loki episodes and then we also have rick
and morty episodes rick and morty season five is
starting next week so i'll be doing videos for
that too every week ten episodes in season five
but we finally actually have some marvel movies
that we can go see or you could stay home and
watch them on disney plus pretty much either way
you want to go but if you have any questions about
what's going on with the movie or what's going on
with loki or anything else in the mcu just let me
know in the comments if there's any special
bonus videos that you want me to do everyone
click here for my full loki episode 1 video
and click here for that brand new loki avengers
secret wars teaser thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!